Transcription: Matt Leedham
Relecteur: eric vautier
Sachez que les physiciens
sont des êtres étranges,
comme vous le voyez.
Pas de bol pour vous,
je suis un physicien.
Des collègues physiciens ont étudié
un problème bien plus essentiel
pour votre vie
que les innombrables choses qu’on apprend
à la télévision ou dans les livres.
Il s’agit - j’espère que
vous êtes assis et assise -
il s’agit de l’art efficace, efficace -
tenez-vous bien -
de verser la pâte dans une poêle à crêpes.
Bien entendu, l’idée est d’avoir
une crêpe sans trous,
mais sans utiliser une quantité
trop importante de pâte non plus.
Je vous passe les détails sur
l'augmentation de la viscosité de la pâte
qui est fonction de l'augmentation
de la température.
C’est un peu comme pour
l’huile de vidange, en fait.
Les collègues physiciens ont
montré qu’il fallait verser le liquide
sur une casserole très inclinée en
lui imprimant un double mouvement.
D’abord, de rotation pour faire
répartir uniformément la pâte
et ensuite le redressement de la casserole
afin d’avoir une épaisseur constante.
En gros, les camarades physiciens
ont montré,
avec tout un tas
d’équations over compliquées,
ce que ma maman m’avait appris à faire
avec un simple tablier.
Faire moins, mais plus,
c’est quand même un peu
le thème de la conférence,
nécessite de verser moins de liquide
dans la casserole.
En retour, vous aurez plus de galettes.
L’idée n’est pas sotte en soi.
On va résoudre ensemble le paradoxe
inhérent au proverbe de nos grands-mères :
« Avoir le beurre et l’argent du beurre ».
Avoir le beurre et l’argent du beurre
signifie aussi
que lorsque vous allez recevoir
les amis à la maison,
vous leur servirez plus de verres,
mais moins de liquide.
Si vous faites des verres moins remplis,
vous en tirez plus de la même bouteille.
CQFD.
Quod erat demonstrandum,
pour le dire en latin.
Un petit latinisme à placer ce soir,
pourquoi pas.
Quod erat demonstrandum.
En d’autres termes, on peut être
à la fois amphitryon
et harpagon.
C’est même conseillé si on aime recevoir
et que le budget n’est pas illimité.
Il y a deux manières de faire cela.
La première est totalement malhonnête.
C’est l’astuce que j’avais utilisée
quand, gamin,
je tirais la gnôle
de la bouteille des parents
et je remettais à niveau
avec l’eau du robinet.
Expérience vécue.
Ça fonctionne tant que la
bouteille reste au fond de l’armoire.
Et puis, évidemment, la recette s’effondre
dès que les victimes s’offrent un verre.
L’autre manière de faire est
moins directement malhonnête.
Vous allez, nous allons, manipuler
les indices environnementaux.
C’est le terme exact et consacré.
De quoi s’agit-il ?
On va modifier des repères,
visuels notamment,
afin de perturber le jugement
de nos invités.
Un de ces repères est la taille du verre.
Pour comprendre la chose,
regardez le transparent qui est affiché.
Vous avez deux verres de jus rouges.
Spontanément,
sans tricher,
à votre avis, quel verre contient
le plus de jus rouge ?
On pencherait pour le grand verre
en vérité,
alors qu’on sait qu’on a mis
la même quantité de liquide
dans les deux verres.
Pourquoi ? Parce que notre œil prend comme
référence la taille du verre, justement.
Pour en avoir le cœur net,
comme clarinette,
on a récupéré 198 étudiants
à l’université de l’Illinois, aux USA.
On leur a demandé de servir
des shots de 4,40 cl.
Ça fait pile poil une once et demie
dans leurs unités locales
qui ne sont absolument pas
internationales.
Ils devaient...
(Rires)
Ils devaient servir des shots dans les
verres alternativement hauts et étroits,
et larges et bas.
Et nos amis étudiants,
ils ont servi 30% de plus dans
les verres, en fait, larges et bas.
En quelque sorte, si vous voulez,
ils ont compensé l’effet d’optique.
Bon, vous me direz : « Ok, ok,
mais ce sont les jeunes.
Ils ne servent pas des shots
tous les jours que Dieu fait. »
On l'espère en tout cas.
Mais qu’en est-il
des serveurs professionnels ?
Les serveurs professionnels,
on ne peut plus dire ça,
on doit dire des mixologues.
Attention, c’est le même métier,
mais ça fait plus chic.
Donc on a demandé à nos mixologues
de servir des shots.
Et bardaf !
Ah oui, on est à Bordeaux.
« Bardaf », c’est du belge,
ça veut dire « patatras » en belge.
Donc bardaf ! -
maintenant qu’on le sait tous -
ça n’a pas loupé.
Ils ont servi 20% de plus
dans les verres larges et bas.
En résumé de résumé, si
vous invitez des amis à la maison,
privilégiez des verres hauts et étroits.
De cette manière, alors que
vos invités croiront avoir plus,
vous leur servirez moins.
Il me semble que c’est la -
(Applaudissements)
Il me semble que c’est l’application la
plus efficace, concrète et pratique -
surtout pratique parce qu’on oublie
parfois la praticité
de notre fameuse maxime,
« du moins avec plus ».
Passons maintenant
à nos amis restaurateurs.
Une expérience assez intéressante a été
réalisée à l’École hôtelière de Lausanne,
un établissement très réputé.
Ils ont comparé dans un restaurant
le service des verres de vin
sur deux semaines.
Lors de la première semaine,
le verre de vin était proposé
à cinq ou sept francs suisses.
C’est Lausanne, évidemment,
ils n’ont pas l’euro.
Donc les verres de vin à cinq
ou sept francs suisses, première semaine,
et seconde semaine,
les verres de vin étaient proposés
avec une suggestion un peu pompeuse
que vous avez déjà sans doute vue
du type « accord de notre sommelier »
ou une autre bonimenterie du style.
Le transparent qui est affiché vous
indique les choix des clients
en fonction des semaines, bien sûr.
Regardez les colonnes rouges :
lors de la première semaine,
qui est indiquée
« contrôle » sur la gauche,
vous voyez qu’environ une personne
sur quatre, un peu moins de 25%,
a choisi le verre de vin qui, pour rappel,
n’était pas mis en avant dans le menu.
Lors de la seconde semaine
qui est indiquée à droite -
la semaine dite ‘suggestions’ -
vous voyez la colonne rouge ?
On est presque à 75 %.
Donc, trois clients sur quatre ont
choisi l’un ou l’autre des verres de vin.
L’astuce dans l’astuce
si vous regardez les colonnes vertes,
c’est que l’augmentation
la plus importante,
est le fait des vins les moins chers.
Un peu comme si on disait moins cher,
mais plus de verres.
En d’autres termes, le client se dit :
« OK, je suis un peu le dindon de la farce
mais je n’ai pas envie
d’être totalement plumé. »
Bon, OK, OK.
Mais tant qu’on est sur
ces histoires de restaurants,
je dois faire état avec vous de longues
années de recherche très personnelles
à user mon fond de culotte
sur les chaises de restaurant.
Ne prenez jamais mesdames et
messieurs l’accord mets et vins,
le menu vin compris ou les vins du
sommelier, c’est une arnaque intégrale.
Intégrale !
(Applaudissements)
Vous boirez des petits vins inconnus
dont vous me direz des nouvelles.
La seule nouvelle, justement, c’est
qu’ils gagnent à rester inconnus.
(Rires)
Donc on est sur ces histoires de
verres de vin ou de vins au verre.
Selon vous, quel type de vin peut
se servir le plus facilement au verre ?
Le service du verre de vin,
ce n’est pas, bien sûr,
d’extraire le liquide de la bouteille.
Le physicien vous dira qu’en gros
tous les vins se valent.
Mais l’idée étant de pouvoir servir un
verre aujourd’hui, un autre demain
et un autre après-demain,
de la même bouteille qui devient
de ce fait une bouteille entamée
et d’avoir toujours un liquide
tout aussi bon.
Ne cherchez pas, il ne s'agit pas de vin
rouge, pas de vin blanc, pas de vin rose,
pas de vin effervescent, pas
de vin orange, de vin bleu,
ou que sais-je encore.
Il s’agit de vins liquoreux
comme le Sauternes.
Le Sauternes est une magnifique région de
production s’étendant du sud de Bordeaux
jusqu’à Langon, à peu près,
sur 2 000 hectares.
Vous êtes peut-être comme moi ;
en tout cas, pour moi,
le terme « hectare » a souvent été
familier à mes portugaises,
à mes oreilles si vous voulez,
mais sa représentation planaire
n’était pas tout à fait concrète.
Pensez qu’un terrain de football,
c’est sept dizaines d’hectares.
Donc vous avez très exactement 2857
terrains de football à Sauternes.
C’est déjà plus clair, bien sûr.
(Rires)
Avec mes étudiants
à l’Université Libre de Bruxelles,
on a réalisé une expérience assez subtile,
que l’on appelle
un « test de résistance à l’air ».
De quoi s’agit-il ?
En vérité, on va éventer le vin,
on va le mettre en contact avec l’air,
et on va voir comment
le liquide se comporte,
s’il est toujours tout aussi bon.
En général, ce type d’expérience se
déroule sur une durée de 24 heures,
guère plus.
Mais nous, on a un brin exagéré la chose.
Un chouia, comme on dit.
On est monté jusqu’à cinq semaines
après l’ouverture.
(Rires)
Je vous résume.
On avait donc six bouteilles du même vin,
du même vin de Sauternes.
La première, et c’est ici
où je me plante toujours,
la première avait été ouverte
dès l’expérience.
La seconde a été ouverte
une semaine auparavant.
La troisième, deux semaines auparavant
et ce jusqu’à la sixième bouteille
qui a donc été ouverte
cinq semaines auparavant.
Six bouteilles, cinq intervalles de temps.
On a bien sûr mélangé ces bouteilles.
On les a anonymisées, et on les
a fait déguster par des juges,
en leur demandant d’utiliser les codeurs
officielles, classiques, canoniques,
pour les vins liquoreux
comme le Sauternes.
Le transparent affiché vous indique
la représentation graphique
de cette opération.
On l’appelle le fameux diagramme en radar.
Vous voyez que les figures
se superposent, en vérité.
Les juges n’ont pas été capables
de distinguer la bouteille
qui avait été ouverte des autres.
Ils n’ont pas pu distinguer
aucune des bouteilles des autres.
Dans leurs têtes de juge, ils dégustaient
exactement le même vin.
Pensez-y la prochaine fois que
vous ouvrirez un vin de Sauternes :
elle se conserve magnifiquement
bien, ouverte et entamée
dans la porte du frigo jusqu’à cinq
semaines après l’ouverture.
(Applaudissements)
Un peu comme si on disait : « On peut
boire moins, mais plus longtemps. »
(Rires)
On a commencé cette petite discussion
en signalant que les physiciens
étaient des êtres étranges.
Sachez que les médecins
ne le sont pas moins.
En 1765, a été défendue une thèse
à la faculté de médecine
de l’université de Reims
par un certain Pourfour du Petit.
Pourfour du Petit, c’est son nom.
Il ne l’a pas choisi, c’est comme ça,
Pourfour du Petit.
Voilà.
Le titre de la thèse de
Pourfour du Petit était le suivant -
j’espère que vous êtes assis :
« An inter edendum ostrea meri potus ? »
Je répète : « An inter edendum
ostrea meri potus ?  »
En français de France,
cela pourrait donner,
la traduction la plus proche possible :
« Faut-il boire du vin
en mangeant des huîtres ? »
Tout de suite, on constate que
les docteurs régents de l’époque
avaient des considérations aussi
essentielles pour l’avenir de l’humanité
et la sauvegarde de l’espèce humaine
que nos physiciens crêpiers du début.
Quelle a été la réponse
de Pourfour du Petit ?
Il a conclu par la négative.
Il ne faut pas boire de vin
en mangeant des huîtres.
De ma modeste expérience,
ce n'est pas si idiot.
Encore heureux, vous me direz, c’est une
thèse en latin, que ce ne soit pas idiot.
Mais en vérité, les huîtres,
c’est extrêmement salé.
Certes, ce n’est pas l’eau de mer
dont la teneur en sel est
de 35 grammes par litre,
mais c’est presque tout comme.
Ce qui fait que tous les vins blancs, tels
les Chablis, les Sancerre, les Pessac
se font démonter, tous.
Tous, presque tous.
Parce que si on prend un vin liquoreux
comme le Sauternes dont on a parlé,
là, on a un accord magique.
On a un accord régressif, celui qui vient
activer la partie reptilienne du cerveau,
que ce soit la gauche ou la droite,
le fameux accord sucré-salé.
Tout ceci pour dire que notre Pourfour
du Petit avait eu le nez creux.
Quelque part, il proposait de
boire moins, voire pas du tout,
afin d’avoir plus de plaisir gustatif.
Mais là où l’histoire se corse,
où les Romains s’empoignent -
vous faites comme vous voulez -
c’est qu’on a retrouvé l’exemplaire
annoté par le recteur de l’époque,
un certain Louis-Jérôme Raussin.
Il indique, en marge de son calepin,
la chose suivante :
« Monsieur Pourfour du Petit a menti, » -
ça part mal quand même -
“il faut, en mangeant des huîtres,
boire du bon vin blanc
de Champagne léger, non mousseux.
Il est à croire que l’auteur de cette
thèse (président ou bachelier)
a été déçu par les mauvais vins
que l’on débite à Paris
sous le nom de Génétin
ou sous celui de Condrieu.
Si ce gaillard avait mangé des
huîtres en buvant de la tisane d’Ay,
d’Hautvillers, d’Épernay, etc.,
il aurait rectifié sa conclusion
et se serait souhaité :
Collum, fauces sesquipedales.
Ah, la bourrique ! »
Fin de citation.
(Applaudissements)
On comprend que le recteur
n’est pas extrêmement satisfait
du travail du doctorant.
Mais peut-être que le « collum fauces »
nécessite un brin d’explications.
Cela signifie littéralement, le cou et les
maxillaires, la bouche grande ouverte.
Donc, selon le recteur de Reims, si
Pourfour du Petit avait mangé des huîtres
avec du bon vin blanc de champagne,
il se serait souhaité le gosier
le plus large possible
afin d’en manger plus.
En bon défenseur des produits du terroir
et de leurs producteurs,
le recteur rémois proposait de boire plus
pour que les vignerons n’aient pas moins.
De boire plus pour que
les vignerons n’aient pas moins.
Et là, vous avez constaté
qu’on introduit subrepticement,
en loucedé, pourrait-on dire,
(Rires)
une négation dans le « moins, mais plus »
qui a fait la métaphore de tout l’exposé.
Cette négation, en catimini,
eh bien, elle nous amène
au dernier point de notre affaire,
un élément de logique formelle.
Si vous en êtes d’accord, nous terminerons
par un élément de logique formelle.
Pourquoi la logique formelle,
cher Monsieur ?
Parce que ce sont les choses
que j’enseigne à l’université
avec les mathématiques de l’incertitude.
Eh oui !
Eh oui, je n’enseigne pas que la gnôle.
(Rires)
Cet élément de logique vous permettra
d’obtenir ce que vous voulez,
où vous le voulez, quand vous le voulez
et en quantité que vous le voulez.
Si ceci n’est pas moins, mais plus,
moins mais plus au carré,
c’est le beurre, l’argent du beurre,
le sourire, la crémière
du crémier en prime,
je ne sais pas ce qu’il faut.
Bref, pour ne pas se gourer, nous allons
partir d’un principe inébranlable,
inattaquable et indestructible.
C’est le fameux « ex falso quodlibet »,
c’est le dernier, je vous rassure.
Ex falso : du faux,
quodlibet : ce que l’on souhaite.
En d’autres termes,
si la prémisse est fausse,
on peut démontrer ce que l’on veut.
Bien entendu, ce principe est utilisé
tous les jours par l’homme de la rue
afin de bâtir ses argumentations
sur une base saine.
Mais il peut avoir
des conséquences inattendues.
Prenez par exemple la phrase suivante :
« Si deux et deux font cinq,
alors je suis Napoléon. »
Cette phrase est un peu alambiquée,
en effet,
mais elle est vraie
d’un point de vue logique.
Parce que deux et deux
ne faisant pas cinq,
il n’est pas faux de dire,
il est vrai de dire que
si deux et deux font cinq,
alors je suis Napoléon.
Ex falso - deux et deux font cinq,
quodlibet - je suis Napoléon.
Notez que quodlibet, quodlibet,
j’aurais pu dire,
« Je suis la reine d’Angleterre »,
ça ne change rien
que je sois Napoléon
ou la reine d’Angleterre.
Muni de ces sages préceptes,
vous pourriez,
à l’issue de cette conférence,
vous tourner vers votre voisin ou
votre voisine et lui susurrer à l’oreille
la chose suivante, qu’on va afficher pour
la bonne compréhension des opérations.
« Si ce que je dis est vrai,
offrez-moi un verre de vin. »
Votre voisin ou voisine n’a aucune envie
de vous offrir un verre de vin.
On sait tous où ça commence,
on ne sait jamais où ça s’arrête.
Vous allez lui demander un dîner au
restaurant, une villa pour les vacances,
une place pour la prochaine
conférence TEDx.
Donc stop ! Halte là ! Halte là !
On va considérer que vous dites
le faux, mais disant le faux,
le début de la phrase, « si ce que
je dis est vrai » est faux,
et si la prémisse est fausse,
l’ensemble de la phrase devient vrai.
Ex falso quodlibet.
Patatras, (Rires) patatras !
On est tombé à deux pieds joints
dans le piège,
et encore, en prenant garde de
ne pas marcher à côté du piège.
On a considéré que la phrase était fausse
et on en a dérivé qu’elle est vraie.
Cela ne se peut.
C'est un paradoxe.
La seule option qui reste, c’est de
considérer que la phrase est vraie
et de vous offrir un verre
de vin, comme de juste.
Si ce que je dis est vrai,
la conférence est terminée.
(Applaudissements)